But when we date discriminative
classification we said, you know nearest
neighbor has some power, but, it can be
kind of expensive in terms of storage
and access, and maybe there
are better ways we can do things.
And in fact,
we talked about training classifiers, so
we talked about boosting or SVM.
So, we can do that for
this example, too, right?
I have a whole bunch
of images of violins.
I've got a whole bunch
of images of people.
of images of planes.
I take all those images together,
I find all the visual words.
All right, that gives me a vocabulary.
I can build a histogram for
each of the objects.
And you know, so I've brought
a bunch of training data, so
I got a bunch of histograms for
planes, I've got histograms for
cars, histograms for faces.
And what do I do?
I just train a support vector machine
to make the decision, you know,
is this a, a person,
a plane, a car, et cetera.
And in fact that's
exactly what was done.
This work comes from 04.
There was a database, still is a
database referred to as the Caltech 101.
It was one of the original
datasets of enough images of
enough object types to start to explore
this notion of database access.
And, and what they were doing was
they trained exactly a linear SVM,
we talked about those before,
using a bag of words on vectors and
there were a couple
of different classes.
Faces, airplanes, cars,
motorbikes, et cetera.
And what's being reported here is that
for each of the actual faces, you know,
out of, you know,
the average percentage of time.
That it was the best rank was 94, 96,
90 so you can see that it's pretty good.
And then the other thing that
they report is the mean rank.
So when I try to find, you know,
whether or not, you know,
when I show a plane and I say well,
do I think it's a plane,
do I think its a face,
do I think its a motorbike, et cetera?
You know, how what is the average
ranking of the correct answer?
And you can see the value
is 1.0 something.
Meaning that it almost
always got the answer right.
But it was just an example of this
bag of words approach that says,
I don't know anything about parts,
I don't know anything about structure.
What I know about is images and
I take locations and
images and I find interesting points,
I build some description.
Give me a word-like collection
of those descriptors.
And then for any new image, try to
find the descriptors that are present.
And that's what's referred
to as bag of words.